in modern history you have these UFOs
landing and communicating with like
children you have the aerial School
event which these children lisel and
Salma they were like within a meter of
these beings the message that the aliens
that visited that school in Africa gave
to the children was you're trashing the
planet you have to change this and that
was so much before that was a thing in
humanity right wasn't there like 30
school children there's a bunch there's
a b yeah full school I asked lisel one
of the two girls why do you think they
said that to you she said to me I think
doing it now I go what do you mean she
goes just talking about it I think that
was the point spreading the word spread
the word the other thing it makes me
think of is that old Twilight Zone from
the' 60s where they find the book that
the aliens had to serve man was the name
of the book they translated it and at
the end the famous line is it's a
cookbook to serve man will you text me
that episode